Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at what
makes pop rocks pop.
Much like other hard sugar candies, Pop Rocks
are made primarily of sugar, corn syrup, water,
and artificial flavoring.
What causes the candy to pop when it comes
in contact with the moisture and heat in your
mouth is not due to any ingredient.
Rather, it is due to the way the candy is
made.
In a nutshell, the ingredients are first combined,
stirred and heated up, bringing the mixture
to boil.
They continue to boil it until the moisture
level descends suitably so that a thick syrupy
substance remains.
In normal hard sugar candies, this substance
is then put in molds and allowed to cool and
harden.
However, with pop rocks, they expose the hot
mix to carbon dioxide at about 600 pounds
per square inch . This causes very small bubbles
of carbon dioxide to form within the mixture.
The substance is then cooled and subsequently
hardens.
Once the hard candy is formed, the pressure
is released.
This causes the candy to shatter, leaving
small nuggets of hard candy, which are the
Pop Rocks.
Many of these nuggets still contain pockets
of carbon dioxide kept at relatively high
pressure.
When the candy hits the saliva in your mouth,
it quickly dissolves the thin barriers containing
the pressurized carbon dioxide, resulting
in the bubbles bursting, often with sufficient
force to cause the candy to jump in your mouth.
BONUS FACT
Pop Rocks were invented by Chemist William
A. Mitchell, who worked for General Foods.
He also invented Tang, Cool Whip, quick-setting
Jell-O, a tapioca substitute, and powdered
egg whites, among other things.
In total, he received over 70 patents in his
lifetime.
So I hope you enjoyed this video, if you did
please give it a like below.
Also, coming up Simon and I are thinking of
doing a bit of a Q&A video, so if you have
any questions for us, please leave them in
the comments below.
Thanks for watching!